what a fun what a fun weekend it was
just watching basketball watching nba
finals bubble ball is over so we've got
the lakers
winning the 17th title in team history
win last night over the miami heat
and lebron james again
finals mvp
fourth title
fourth finals mvp and you watched it it
was you were you excited i mean after
friday night friday night what a
thrilling game miami stays alive
draws to 3-2 jimmy butler another great
game
uh following a great game three so
another great game five triple double
and then here you are last night game
six
where the lakers closed it out what were
you thinking just watching all this
stuff
i mean i was thankful
for friday night because i knew that no
matter what on monday we'd have
something fresh remember i told you i
was like yes but at least look worst
case scenario
we're talking about the end of the
finals from sunday we may be looking
ahead to a game seven
uh so i was excited after friday night
friday night gave us so much which feels
dated now
um you know lebron's decision
to pass to danny green
the unfortunate
backlash that danny green and his
fiancee received uh jimmy butler and
that iconic at least for a weekend or at
least for a couple of days that iconic
photo of him being exhausted and hunched
over and
and what he what he might have in store
as an encore for game six so i was
i still like to say i was really
disappointed last night just in terms of
the game was just not competitive
but so it was it was the coronation that
many people like you expected this
series to be uh based on how the series
had played out i thought we may get a
game seven but man that adjustment props
to frank vogel that adjustment to
to start uh
caruso and place it to white howard i
mean they just came out and and they i
don't know if is it politically correct
for me to say this if not i'll i'll pay
the consequences
um
but the lakers beat the heat with the
extension cord
i mean
you know i mean
they
they told the heat i mean listen i know
we're in a different day and age i know
i know i know you know we've evolved as
a people but hey listen you know i tell
you let's go let me let me tell you what
i'm telling why it's not politically
incorrect
okay cool some people
some people of a certain age out there
remember
what that was yes before before parents
were enlightened uh before they
shouldn't be doing before before
that kind of stuff they they totally
heat to go pick out the switch
okay go get the go get the switch
i don't know if you've
well or michael
have you ever gotten it wet did you ever
get it while in the bathtub
yeah
i still i still remember that one so
that was a bathtub ass whipping that the
lakers put on last night
that's the kind you don't ever really
forget you know don't try this at home
parents young parents yes exactly not
condoning this we're laughing about it
laughing about it because i don't
understand thankfully we survived it you
know but a long time ago exactly a long
time ago
exactly right they jumped up so they
really did and you know mike i remember
i told you this before and we'll see i
mean you never really know what a team
is until you have some distance
from that team unless you're just
ridicul it's just like an all-time great
team
like the 72 and 10 bulls they win a
championship and you can say in the
moment wow this team is really really
good but some other teams it takes a
while for you to figure out
where they fit in nba history i still
think that this lakers team is better
than is giving that that is given credit
for right now in the moment we're going
to look back in in two or three years
and say wow that team
it's pretty good especially mike
especially
if
three four five members of the team
are on the team next year and a year
after because not only do they win this
championship michael smith
um i i see no reason why they won't be
back
in this space on this stage
again next year
and perhaps the year after
this this is not a
one-off for the lakers oh it was a
pandemic
it was the strange just strange times
in the world and in sports and then next
year was going to go back to somebody
else no
no get used to seeing these lakers this
iteration
lebron james
still being the guy
but having a very very very close number
two not even number two maybe even a 1a
in in anthony davis so they're going to
be around for a while
all right so yeah i don't i don't want
to get too far ahead but yeah let's i'll
stay here for a minute with you and say
one i think this duo this tandem of
lebron and anthony davis one of the
you know few times in nba history we've
seen
uh two first-team all-nba teammates this
duo
even with quote-unquote just one
championship i put this duo against
pretty much any duo that's ever done it
for the most part you know you talk
about
talent uh with with two people
um
i i do think history will
view this team kindly in context
because we've talked a lot forget about
the construction of the roster and and
you know the pieces and top to bottom
talent just
the accomplishment
of being able to
and i don't want to
i don't want to make it sound like they
were uh
you know they were in the jungle
somewhere but i mean to survive the
bubble you know i mean it was yesterday
it was disney world yes it was a hotel
it's not insignificant though that's not
insignificant yes and and i think it's
it's a singular achievement uh
singular team accomplishment yeah on one
hand previous nba champions had to
actually go on the road into hostile
environments the bubble was not a
hostile environment in a traditional
sense but nonetheless uh to be the team
to to to grind through this this
challenge of of of winning this bubble
championship
no matter how much some people might
want to discredit it psychologically
this was unlike any other championship
and so i think history will certainly
remember these lakers for that
achievement